if you're looking for a good time it's
never a bad idea to find janet ivanovic
now four decades into her blockbuster
career she continues to pump out best
seller after bestseller that includes
our most recent the 27th book
in the hugely popular stephanie plum
series but the first that's not directly
named after a number
there was one for the money two for the
show and many more now to mix things up
a bit
fortune and glory
i like to work seven days a week
i take you know some half days off to do
whatever but
i like the continuity like to stay in
the story
janet ivanovic has earned enough to do
anything she wants these days
but she still chooses to spend 60 or 70
hours a week
sitting in this chair writing i have no
hobbies
i hate sports i don't like to sweat i
don't swim i don't run
i don't i don't do anything you sit your
butt in the chair and write yeah that's
what i do
we met ivanovic at her current spot in
south florida
one of the places where her singular
obsession on sentence and story has
turned out an astounding 25
number one new york times best sellers
what i need to get is a job husband
the most famous part of that production
features fictional bounty hunter
stephanie plum
played in the 2012 movie one for the
money by katherine heigl
they blew up my car excuse me whose car
your car
you want it back stephanie is you to
some extent
ivanovic has done 27 books featuring
plum
the new one fortune in glory has plum in
a search for mafia treasure
alongside the usual hijinx romance and
her sometime partner
lula you can call the novels lowbrow
in just the first couple pages of the
new book um we've got
a detailed discussion of nipples yes and
we're off to the races yes because um
lula has nipple radar
as you know do all women but you cannot
say the books aren't
entertaining even if you did it's
unlikely ivanovic would care
i'm the writer that writes the happy
books you know i'm the writer that you
know it's going to end well
we don't kill any cats and dogs there's
a little sex in it you know there's
always a couple hot guys
and so you know and these are promises
that i make to my reader i think it's
important that you keep the promise
it's a promise ivanovic has been trying
to keep since she first started writing
in her 30s
after raising two kids she found some
early success with
romance novels lots of clinching here
they're very tasteful clinches
that's true are they tasteful inside but
shirley broke through with her unique
brand of detective writing
as she explained to anthony mason in
1997
for cbs sunday morning stephanie plum
lost her
virginity behind the seyclair case this
very
this very eclair case yes you know if
you could hand pick a place wouldn't
that be high on your list
right there huh yeah yeah that was
amazing
i hadn't done a whole lot of stuff like
that before you know and so i felt like
a real movie star
i didn't get a hockey jersey though
today i dressed up for you today
thank you
[Laughter]
ivanovich credits the plum character's
style in large part to the great 1988
bounty hunter comedy
midnight run starring robert de niro and
charles grodin
you guys
today ivanovich has sold more than a
hundred million books
i mean the success that i've had i mean
that that's unreal
that's a whole other deal it's insane
yes it's a lot of books
yes it's very good it is really good
but it's also interesting because
there's only been one movie and that
surprises me
yeah me too i want more
yeah i want television i want movies
that's coming though
yeah we're working on it and you know
and i'm kind of surprised because i
think that my writing is actually very
cinematic
ivanovich does have several tv and film
projects in development
that she's hoping will top the
underwhelming performance of
one for the money a movie she says she
was creatively
sidelined from in the meantime she's
still moving
at her predictably ridiculous pace i
outline a day or two ahead
as i go and already promoting two new
books
scheduled for next year well janet this
has been
an absolutely wonderful experience
virtual tours book wise while necessary
still suck yeah yeah that's that's a
good way to put it it sucks
it really does and you don't get to see
any of the
readers i'm getting used to it i'm
starting to figure it out
um i actually i went out and i got a
beauty light you know
so that i have the appropriate lighting
on me now
but you know it's it's just not the same
it isn't it isn't any fun
it's i think it's better than nothing is
there is there any world in which you
see yourself
not doing this every day no
janet says she actually ages in reverse
or just or stopped
stopped she does look great or stopped
aging so she's actually younger than her
children now
and based on her output you have to
believe her i mean she just keeps going
70 hours a week
every single day she spends between 8
and 10 hours a day writing in that chair
living in these worlds and this is why
she has created these worlds
that are um so attractive to so many
people
and her back go ahead our backyard
doesn't look too bad no
no not not a terrible place i was sold
on the midnight run reference
oh my gosh absolutely sold everyone